time of year
chief meteorologist ted florento in the
house right now focusing on some weather
trends some heat some reduction in heat
production and and yeah heat for sure
and then more dust right oh yeah yeah i
know i'm excited about that but if you
think our dust is bad you guys see this
video out of iraq whoa that is nothing
wrong with our camera filter that
actually is dust there guys take a look
out of iraq climate experts are there
are raising a red flag over a series of
sandstorms they say this happens every
season in the region but never like this
guys they're blaming drought and
government officials for poor water
management including policies too so
horrible there right i feel like my
allergies are going crazy just by just
watching that right and of course if
they anybody has any uh they have air
quality issues anybody has like asthma
out there poor air quality with with
that issue out there we're gonna have
dust here too that's gonna kick up again
i promise you nothing like that but
still our fair share of dust we're going
to show you one coming up live look
outside though beautiful day out there
temperatures are hot of course
and then a little breezy in some spots i
want to pinpoint out to you though our
latest weather alert this is our only
one so far it's a fire weather watch
issued again for all the southern nevada
here and into also arizona as well that
begins thursday 11 a.m goes all the way
until friday at 8 pm those two days
because we're going to have an elevated
fire danger due to what wind and also
the low humidity which will be less than
10 percent including the heat that we'll
have on thursday currently outside 95 in
centennial hills and up there in sky
canyon 94 spring valley 98 north las
vegas 99 double nines for you out on the
east side there sunrise manor 98 green
valley 94 mountains edge anthem 96 if
your neighborhood isn't on here don't
worry i got you covered we'll switch up
our neighborhoods every newscast 93 prep
103 death valley wait and see your
temperature tomorrow death valley 96 for
boulder city 99 for lafayette there are
storms out there they're popping up some
convection up here way in the northern
lincoln county see kellyanne is down
here we're seeing it up in ely to even
some lightning strikes along with that
drifting all the way into utah like we
said unfortunately none of this is going
to reach us here as we stay and remain
dry and will that way be that way also
for this evening once that sun goes down
that loss of daytime heating all those
storms up there also are going to end as
well wind forecast does have a little
bit of a breeze tonight but then notice
tomorrow those colors go away so
wednesday looks good but thursday
and not so much look at this so we see
those gusty winds return on thursday
again that's going to be our windiest
day but that happens to show us a big
temperature drop here you go kirsten
your favorite graphic
one she shouldn't expect this 101 on
thursday here we go 101 thursday and
[Music]
oh you're then me
87 on friday look at that temperature
drop almost 15 degrees so i told you we
get back to the 80s we're going to see
that this week 71 degrees overnight
breezy this evening but mild in the
morning so that's your morning start 71
degrees tomorrow 98 hot and dry really
less than 15 percent less than 10
percent for humidity
lighter winds for tomorrow after this
business behalf of the day today here
neighborhood some of you will reach the
century mark again that is sunrise manor
in green valley 197 spring valley but we
might not reach it officially which we
take the temperature official
temperature out of mccarran 112 for you
out in death valley 102 for laughlin 96
boulder city here's your eight day
forecast there's that big temperature
drop from thursday to friday along with
wind in the next week
like a weekend but next week we're right
back to the triple digits that's your
most accurate weather update guys we'll
send it over to you no break